you've got five columns a week that
you're right at the moment that's
correct i write an average of four
crimes a week okay yeah uh well plus
media spots plus writing a book plus the
other bits that you do plus trying to
have a life as well
what is it that drives you
to work that hard
um
gosh that's a difficult question um
i i do work very hard uh
i got to see this first hand yeah the
reason i bring it up
yeah
i um
i think i might have mentioned you i
sometimes have to register that with
myself a few weeks ago i got back maybe
it was when you were in new york i
remember i got
home one night at about 10 p.m and i
remember having this terrible feeling
but there must be something i've got to
do
and i rise
oh no there isn't
i can relax
and at 10 pm at night and that is not
uncommon
at all
um i i sort of say that
one of the great
benefits of the life i've been able to
create has been that i i
i work in
in
uh industries trades whatever you want
to call them
where i have to work all of the time
but at about 90 or 80 percent
so
most people work well let's pretend that
most people work 95 100 percent
um and then they stop working
and they can do whatever they like the
rest of the time um
uh if you
do what you love
well first of all if you're very busy in
the summer as i i'm in you just can't do
a nine-to-five job i mean it wouldn't
work
uh
and so yeah i work all the time uh
every day i have something i don't think
is it ever a day when i don't
what drives that uh
a lot of things i suppose one is just
being driven
and i don't know if anyone can explain
for themselves why someone why they're
driven i just i just know i always have
been
i always had a um a horror of wasting
time
i mean i i i
i'm quite an irritable person it's one
of my
um traits don't smile
you were perfectly pleasant when i said
okay well that's very good um
i'm i'm i'm slightly irritable at times
um
and it's generally because of um a fear
of wasting time
and um
this is very strong
in me
uh i can't bear
clothes shopping for instance i can't
bear being in shops actually in general
i get very irritable because i i just
i feel my life going
and
i have that in certain films and all
sorts of other things i i just have a
very acute sense of
life's brevity
don't waste it
work hard
do whatever it is you're meant to do and
i've got a pretty clear view of what i
need to do
and
so i don't like
not using my time
um
the the other thing i suppose i'm
motivated to be the best that i can be
and that includes being the best in my
field um
i could always do less i mean it's one
of those sort of things that your mother
says you know can you not you know can
you do a bit less
you know something
well i could
but then i wouldn't be as successful and
i want to be successful
um
i i want to do well
you know i
um if i
if i've got a book out like i don't not
promote it
you know because i feel like i've done
the work
um
when you refer to my the columns i write
it's one of the great you know great
pleasures of my life i i get to write
for and speak to millions and millions
of people
in different formats in different
countries in tabloid newspapers and in
broadsheet newspapers
and
enter into and be in
the big debates of my time
and i enjoy it
and you know
people generally think i'm quite good at
it
and
asked me to do it and
um
and i get a thrill from it and and
you know i said a little while ago to a
friend you know i wish i could have a
couple of days off
and then i said i said i wish i could
just like not have to write anything
for a few weeks and she said that you
don't you'd be like 48 hours and you'd
be like damn it then bored you had a
similar experience with meditation i
think
that's right i'm very very bad at
meditating very very bad meditating
yeah i think sam harris wants
to get me to meditate i find that i find
that impossible i'm told that there's a
way to get through that but i couldn't
get through it
i i you know all that thing even when
sam said um
it was in
australia a few years ago
you know samsung was saying like empty
your mind of all your thoughts and i was
just thinking i'm so irritated
um
[Laughter]
god i wish i was reading a book
and i
i
i can't do it and um
[Music]
yeah that's my failing i mean sam is
terrific
and he's brilliant at that and he's
helped
millions of people to find a way to do
things like meditation i wish i could do
that but in a way i don't really because
i kind of don't want to turn my mind off
it's always racing it's always looking
for things and you know i read a lot as
you know um books
and things and
and magazines and articles and what but
i read books uh um
uh and i read to relax as well which is
very important him if you do what i do
um you know you need to extend your
knowledge but you also read things that
just
take you out of
work stuff into something else but even
then
i kind of read with a pencil in my hand
even the relaxing stuff is i have a site
in the corner of my eye i have a friend
who referred to that
before you have the pencil in your hand
there's low stakes consumption
uh so
he talks about low stakes podcast
listening that if you're constantly
embroiled in the culture wars and you're
always listening the newest whatever yes
at 100 miles an hour it's kind of nice
to just hear about a murder mystery for
for a little while low stakes listening
um but yeah
this is something i've been battling
with so much and we spoke about this
with regards to productivity dysmorphia
as well
this tension between
um the fact that you know that part of
your drive
comes from your ability to pay attention
your ability to constantly be on to be
able to look at the details in a way
that other people don't and that that
can actually lead to almost a fear that
you go okay well hang on
if i tune this down
that is the fuel that's driving a lot of
the achievements that i take so much
pleasure in and that there's this
difficulty sometimes with seeing the
amount of work that we've done and i i
think
maybe we almost don't want to see the
amount of work that we've done because
we think well maybe if i took more
satisfaction in the work that i don't
know if i felt if i felt like i could
take more of a break then that might
shortcut some of the things which is
propelling me to continue to do this
well when you start off
you have to work so damn hard
i mean i think that's something that is
not expressed enough to people is it
when you start off your cryptic a career
like mine you you you have to work so
damn hard
in the beginning of my career i didn't
have a holiday for seven years it was
seven years until my family persuaded me
to go away with a holiday i just
couldn't go on holiday and one of the
reasons was
i at the at the beginning of my career
inevitably
if people called and asked me if i could
write something i had to do it
if um i feared that if i said no
they wouldn't come back and ask again
now that's very common
the problem is there is a certain point
in your life when you have that fear and
it's no longer relevant
it's information that you're being told
by yourself about an earlier version of
yourself
and you have the right at a certain
point but it's very hard to make that
decision professionally
um to say okay no i'm okay now i can
take time off i can say no this time
i can't turn that down well you also
need to you need to it's only in the
last 10 years that i learned how to say
no to things
um
because
i didn't know whether i'd be asked again
um
but as for
as for whatever the drive is underneath
that if i could
well i saw yourself revealing but
i suppose there are a couple of things
one is that i've always sought freedom
in my life
[Music]
as much freedom as i can have
and
some years ago i said to
our sort of friends and
some family members around and we're
talking about
various things
i said you know my experience of life
has been that
um
with every year i get more and more free
and i just realized i felt terrible
actually because i rather the younger
guy who's there
i said i i
i don't feel that at all
he had exactly the opposite feeling and
i felt sort of terrible that i said this
but it is sort of been my feeling is
that i've gone further and further in a
way i've gone further and further away
from home you might say
um
and
uh but that i've
wanted to be free and to pursue what i
want to pursue and to have the ability
to do that to write about what i want to
write about to go where i want to go
whatever i want to live and to be with
who i want to be with and this is
this is something i always
wanted and and various others british
journalist suzanne moore said something
quite similar in a piece on her
substance recently and i said to her i
said it just rang such a bell
uh
so that's the first thing and i suppose
the second thing i could probably point
to is that
um
actually slightly
i once said to my late friend clive
james and if you knew a great australian
polymath
i said to him towards the very end of
his life he was born in 1939 an
opening line of his memoirs it says you
know i was born in 1939 the other big
event that year um he's an amazing
wonderful man and but i remember saying
to him once you know about what do you
feel drives you and he lost his father
in the war he didn't die in the war he
lost his father died on the plane back
the americans like brought some of the
australian troops back home early and
the plane crashed and it was just clive
and his mum then you know and i remember
i said to cry once asked him about his
drive and he said i felt like i owed it
to the ruins of my family
um
i do have a sort of sense it's not to do
with family necessarily but
i do have a sense of being
born at a fortunate time
and having had
i don't say luck because i'm for reasons
i think you know i'm worried about the
term luck
but
i feel i have a good fortune which i
shouldn't waste
and you know
most of my predecessors predecessors of
my ancestors did not have very much
freedom
uh economic freedom
freedom to move around
freedom to find stuff out i mean i think
of
the libra you know the sort of the books
that would be on a shelf you know on
sort of grandparents age
relatives
you know they would have very small
numbers of books because people other
than intellectuals or
very rich people people didn't have very
many books you know um
and i
always thought
if i can get the things that my
predecessors couldn't or go to places
they couldn't
why would i waste that
opportunity
um
you know can you imagine how frustrated
you'd be to have been born in the
early 20th century or the late 19th
century
not able to leave your village really
even and
not knowing much about what even
happened in town you know or
let alone in the capital and
you know
and and with every generation
in a country like ours we've had the
ability to go further and further and
it's happened in my own family
and um
so i feel like it's the responsibility
not to waste
that um but more importantly i'm just
driven by the desire not to waste time
you know there's that line of andrew
marvel
behind my back i always hear times
winged chariot hurrying near
i hear times winged chariot awfully loud
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace